the standard question you often get in
your algebra classes they'll give you
this equation and it'll say identify the
conic section and then graph it if you
can and the equation they give you won't
be in the standard form because if it
was you could just kind of pattern match
with what I showed in some of the
previous videos and you'll be able to
get it so let's do a question like that
and let's see if we can figure it out so
what I have here is 9 x squared plus 4 y
squared plus 54 X minus 8 y plus 49 is
equal to 0 and once you I mean this this
knows what this is it's not in the
standard form and actually one quick
clue to tell you what this is is you
look at the the x squared and the y
squared terms if there are I mean if
there's if only there's only an x
squared term and then there's just a Y
and not a y squared term then you're
probably dealing with a parabola and
we'll go into that more later or if it's
the other way around if there's just an
X term and a y squared term is probably
a parabola but assuming that there we're
dealing with a circle and ellipse or
hyperbola there will be an x squared
term and the y squared term if they both
kind of have the same number in front of
it that's a pretty good clue that we're
going to read dealing with the circle if
they both have different numbers but
they're both positive in front of them
that's a pretty good clue we're probably
going to be dealing with an ellipse and
if they both have if one of them has a
negative number in front of them and the
other one has a positive number that
tells you that we're probably going to
be dealing with a hyperbola but with
that said I mean that might help you
identify things very quickly at this
level but it doesn't help you graph it
or get into the standard form so let's
get into the standard form and the key
to getting it in the standard form is
really just completing the square and I
encourage you to rewatch the completing
the square video because that's all
we're going to do right here to get it
into the standard form so the first
thing I like to do to complete this
corner you have to do it in for the X
variables and for the Y terms is group
the x and y term so let's see the X
terms are 9 x squared plus 54 X all
right that's 9 x squared plus 54 X and
let's do the Y terms in magenta so then
you have
plus 4y squared minus 8y and then you
have this let me do this in different
color plus 49 plus 49 is equal to zero
and so the easy thing to do when you
complete the square the thing I like to
do is you know we have these it's very
clear we can factor out a 9 out of both
of these numbers if we could factor out
a 4 out of both of those so let's do
that because that will help us complete
the square so this is the same thing as
9 times x squared plus 9 times 6 is 54
6x I'm going to add something else here
but I'll leave it blank for now plus 4
times y squared minus 2y I'm probably
going to add something here too so I'll
leave it blank for now plus 49 plus 49
is equal to 0 so what we're going to add
here there we're going to complete the
square we want to add some number here
so that this whole 3 term expression
becomes a perfect square and likewise
we're going to add some number here so
that this 3 term number expression
becomes a perfect square and of course
whatever we add on this side we're going
to multiply it by 9 because we're really
adding 9 times that and add it on to
that side and whatever we add here we're
going to multiply it times 4 and add it
on that side because if I put a 1 here
it's really like as if I had a 4 here
because 1 times 4 is 4 and if I have 1
here it's 1 times 9 it's a 9 there so
let's do that so when we complete the
square we just take half of this
coefficient this coefficient is 6 we
take half of it is 3 we square it we get
a 9 but when we remember when it's an
equation so what you do to one side you
have to do the other so if we added a 9
here we're actually adding 9 times 9 to
the left side of the equation so we have
to add 81 to the right hand side to make
the equation still hold and you could
kind of view it if we go back up here
this is the same thing just to make that
clear is if I add a plus 81 right here
plus 81 and of course I would have had
to add plus 81 up here now let's go to
the Y terms you take half of this
coefficient sum
- - half of that is - one you square it
you get plus one one times four so we're
really adding four to the left hand side
of the equation so let's add four here
and just to make just so you understand
what I did here this is the equivalent
is if I just added a four here and then
I later just factored out this four and
found it a four here out of four up here
and so what does this become this
expression is nine times what this is
the square of you could factor this but
we did it on purpose it's X plus three
squared and then we have plus four times
what is this right here that's Y minus
one squared y minus one squared you
might want to review factoring a
polynomial or completing the square if
that if you found that step a little
daunting and then we have plus 49 is
equal to zero plus 81 plus 84 is equal
to 85 all right so now we have 9 times X
plus 3 squared plus 4 times y minus 1
squared and let's subtract 49 from both
sides that is equal to let's see if I
subtract 50 from 85 I get I get 35 so if
I subtract 49 I get 36 36 and now where
it looks we're getting close we're
getting close to a standard form of
something but remember all the standard
forms we did except for the circle we
had a 1 we know this isn't a circle
because we have these weird coefficients
we're not weird but different
coefficients in front of these terms so
to get the 1 on the right hand side
let's divide everything by 36 you divide
everything by 36 this term becomes X
plus 3 squared over C 9 over 36 the same
thing as 1 over 4 and then you have plus
y minus 1 squared for over 36 the same
thing as 1 over 9 and all that is equal
to 1 and there you go we have it in this
standard form and you can see our
intuition at the beginning the problem
was correct this is indeed an ellipse
and now we can actually graph it so
first of all actually good place to
start where is the center of this
ellipse going to be it's going to be at
X is equal to negative 3 right what x
value makes this whole term 0 so it's
going to be X is equal to minus 3 and y
is going to be equal to 1 what makes
what Y value makes this term 0 Y is
equal to 1
that's our Center so let's graph that
and then we can draw the ellipse see
it's going to be in the negative
quadrant so it's our x axis and this is
our y axis and then the center of our
ellipse is that 1 2 3 minus 3 and then
positive 1 so it's that's the center and
then what is the radius in the
x-direction we just take the square root
of this so it's 2 so in the x-direction
we go to to the right so this is 2 let
me go to to the left that's 2 and in the
Y direction what do we do well we go up
3 and down 3 right the square root of
this so let me do that we're going to go
through to c1 1 2 3 so we're going to go
up here I'm going to go 1 2 3 we're
going to go down here that's the Y
alright remember you have to take the
square root of both of those so the D
and so the vertical axis is actually
this the major radius or the semi-major
axis is 3 because that's the longer one
and then this the 2 is the minor radius
because that's a shorter one and now
we're ready to draw this ellipse I'll
draw it in brown so let me see if I can
do this properly you have a shaky hand
all right
it looks something like that and there
you go we took this kind of crazy
looking thing and all we did is
algebraically manipulate it we just
completed the squares with the X's and
the Y terms to get it into and then we
divide both sides by this number right
here and we got it into the standard
form or you said oh this is an ellipse
we have both of these terms where
they're both positive we're adding we're
not subtracting they have different
coefficients underneath here so we're
ready to go over lips and we just we
realize that the center was at -3 1 and
then we just drew the major radius or
the the major axis and the Minor axis
see in the next video